ALVARO VIDELA: I'm Alvaro.
I'm a writer, a developer.
And this is how I code.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I like to work next to my
personal library, going
from book to book,
spreading them
on the floor, over
the bed, over my desk,
trying to find great ideas for
either writing a nice article
or for writing my code.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When trying to solve
programming problems,
it's nice to find the
right framing metaphor that
can help you and guide you
and provide you a vocabulary
to understand the problem.
Think about data replication
in distributed systems.
If you think of that
as gossip, then you
have a very nice way to
explain how replication works.
But there is not really a
good mathematical framework
for that.
But if you think of
replication as epidemics,
there is a whole
theory of epidemics
behind mathematics
that can help you think
and reason about that problem.
You can work your little magic.